ضربه انتقاليه هكذا تقصف موسكو معلنت عنه
من انه هجوم او ذاب حياتي مئات الجنود
الاوكرانيين بعد مقتل العشرات من جنودها
في ليله راس السنه عندما تقوله موسكو
ولكيف حديث اخر لم يسقط مئاته من جنودها
وينافي كلام الروس الحقيقه
اشتد دراواتها لكن ذلك لا يلغي اعلاما
مشتركا من الطرفين عن صفقه تبادل الاسرى
طبله اليوم
ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي سيد اللواء
ما تقوله روسيا بعد انقضاء هذه الهدنه
لانها قصفت موقع في كراماتوستق وانها
اوقعت مئات القتلى كيف تنفي وتقول الجيش
الروسي ليس لديه القدره على تحقيق ذلك انت
ماذا ترى
يعني انا ارى الاتي اذا اخذنا بالاخبار
الاوليه القادمه من اي من طرفي الصراع
وقمنا بجرده حساب لاعداد الخسائر التي تم
ذكرها سواء في الجانب الروسي او في الجانب
الاوكراني ستكون اكثر من 10 اضعاف
الاعتراف عند الحديث عن كيفكم همم روسيا
تقول 89 اوكرانيا الاخبار متباينه لكنها
في النهايه اشارت الى مقتل 4 وجرح 300
الان روسيا تقول مقتل 600 لهذا السبب لابد
ان نتريف قبل ان نتخذ اي راي راي تجاه ما
جرى حتى تتسرب بعض المعلومات لانه ستتسرب
معلومات خلال الاربعه 24 ساعه القادمه
وتقربنا اكثر من الحقيقه لهذا لا استطيع
ان اتبنى اي تصريح من اي من جانبي الصراع
فيما يتعلق بخسائر الجانب الاخر واضرب
مثال
الروس يقول ان قتلاهم لم يصل الى حتى مع
89 لم يصل الى 10,000
اوكرانيا تتحدث عن 100,000 وكذلك اذا
نظرنا من الزاويه الاخرى لهذا السبب نعم
هناك ضربه عدد الخسائر غير معروف لابد ان
ننتظر حتى تتسرب بعض المعلومات
والفيديوهات التي تقربنا من الحقيقه اذا
تتحدث هنا عن ارقام سياسيه وليست ارقام
حقيقيه
ربما في خضم هذه همم الحرب التي يقال بان
الحرب الاعلاميه فيها مشروع على كل حال في
همم في هذه المعارك التي تجري الان
جرت عمليه ناجحه لتبادل الاسرى بين
الطرفين
هل من تفسير علم الدلاله
يعني هذه ليست الاولى ولا الثانيه ولا
الثالثه جرى اكثر من عمليه تبادل سواء
مجندين او سواء مدنيين الى غير ذلك بتبادل
بارقام مختلفه قد تكون في بعض الحالات على
سبيل المثال في شهر ديسمبر
تبادل اسرع في 22 نوفمبر جريتا تبادل اسرع
قبل ذلك اذا دعني اقول لكل حرب جانب
انساني وبالتالي هذه هي البعد الانساني في
هذه الحرب الدمويه التي همم اكلت الاخضر
واليابس ولهذا السبب لا ارى غيرا بان يكون
هناك همم اتفاق على تبادل 50 من كل جانب
وسيكون هناك تبادلات لاحقه مع كلما طال
عمد الحرب الاعلان عن منورات بين روسيا
وبين روسيا الى ماذا تؤشر السيد اللواء
دعنا ننظر الى ذلك من خلال مسيره عده اشهر
ومن خلال زيارات متكرره لرئيس بيلاروسيا
الى روسيا وزياره الرئيس بوتين واستحاضه
وزير الدفاع معه وارسال 15000 مقاتل ومن
ثم ارسال القطار الذي يحمل معدات مع
الحديث عن تزويد بطاريه صواريخ اس 400 الى
غير ذلك وطلب رئيس لوكا شوكو الطلب بتزويد
طائرات اس 35 بي صواريخ قادره على حمل
رؤسناويه الان الحديث همم انه هجوم الربيع
الحديث الاول غير الموفق عن دعوه اخرى
للتجنيد ليكون حجم القوات او العدد الكلي
ما يقارب 500,000 من اجله هجوم الربيع كل
ذلك
ويقابله الحديث
والخطوط الدفاعيه حول والتي تبلغ ااا 1000
كم كل ذلك يوحي ان هناك تحضيرات لهجوم
الربيع سواء من الجانب الاوكراني او من
الجانب الروسي لكن المعطيات الميدانيه من
الان وحتى بدايه شهر ثلاثه ستتحدث تغيير
جواريا في في طبيعه العمليات القادمه لا
نقد تحدث مفاجات ميدانيه سواء بالسيطره
على باخم موت او وبالتالي الاندفاع نحو
كراماتس او السيطره على مدن المثلث
بالمقابل اسلام توفيق وغيرها شكرا هذا
سيغير في المعادله المستقبليه اذا لابد ان
نقرا الواقع ثم نستطيع الحكم شكرا مستقبل
العمليات اللي هو فايز الدويريه الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجي متحدثا من عمان
شكرا لك على اللقاء